this is a production of Cornell
University
yeah I want to thank the students for
inviting me it's always really an honor
to be invited by the students you never
quite know why they picked you but this
is really great so okay so today I'm
going to talk to you about responses to
DNA damage and responses to an acute
dose of heavy DNA damage can go on for
weeks but what we're mostly going to
focus on are these immediate responses
that happen in the very same day is
being hit by this acute dose and these
things have to do with room this is
tricky these these kind of responses are
really responses to the damage that
we're inducing downstream things have
more to do with responses to the
responses you know some cells have died
things have to be replenished I'll talk
about that very briefly because I my
talk is probably too long already ok so
our model dna-damaging agent which we're
going to use throughout this talk or
gamma rays just to make it clear what
gamma rays do the Rays themselves do not
probably induce many double strand
breaks so these are photons they zip
right through the cell the great
majority of them are not even going to
interact with any of the matter in the
self is just going to go right through
but if one is lucky it might interact
probably with a water molecule because
that's most common molecule nacelle it's
going to spit out through Compton
scattering a very high energy electron
that electron can travel quite far in
the cell and if it happens to come to a
stop within the cell it'll depend
deposit all of that energy in a little
burst of reactive oxygen species so this
is really quite an indirect effect but
it's making several different types of
damage right here and again most of the
damage will be to water because most of
the cellular components are water but if
that little burst happens to lodge in
the nucleus it has a good chance of
hitting the DNA and the burst itself
happens within a certain radius which
just by chance is about the same as the
radius of the DNA so you'll get multiple
damage both sides of the DNA and that
means you don't have a good template
strand for repair if possible you could
introduce a break in the backbone to be
but also repair activities will
introduce double strand breaks and this
may take time for those breaks to be
induced so things are going to happen
gradually so again the burst could have
been over here and you get single-sided
damage or if the burst happened to be
right where a DNA molecule was you'll
get a double strand break eventually all
right now double strand breaks sound
terrific but they actually have very
little biological significance provided
the cell doesn't divide so the only
point of having genes be connected to a
chromosome if you're going to do the
cell division again the whole point of
being on a chromosome is to be attached
to a centromere if the cell doesn't need
to divide the DNA can still replicate it
can still do transcription there's no
problem there are many origins of
replication and everything can be just
fine it's only in the context of cell
division that you'd end up losing a
chromosome arm because there's no
centromere here and here in yeast you
would end up with a dead daughter cell
because you've lost a chromosome arm
it's going to carry something that's
essential on there so that's really bad
news but as long as cell division
doesn't happen don't store breaks are
not a problem alright so the immediate
DNA damage response the stuff that
happens in the same day as the DNA
damage is to have some sort of system
for monitoring the presence of damage
and that system has to talk to the cell
and give it some good ideas like
arresting progression of the cell cycle
until that signal disappears maybe
inducing repair if that's something that
needs to happen both bacteria and
eukaryotes extremely exquisitely
sensitive to the presence of
double-strand breaks and in yeast a
single double strand breaks in a
completely unnecessary plasmid will
prevent cell cycle progression now yeast
another single whoops single-celled
organisms if they detect the presence of
a break for several days and it's clear
that it's never going to go away since
their signal set single-celled organism
they might as well give it a shot go on
with replication maybe we'll finally
need that chromosome arm after all and
their daughter so right but in an animal
that's a risky thing to do we carry a
huge genetic load on our chromosomes if
we go from being heterozygous for a
mutation on one of those arms to
uncovering that recessive mutation it
can easily lead to cancer we have
trillions of cells so in our case rather
than adapt to the presence of
double-strand breaks the cell would
decide to die or permanently arrest
instead so that it never undergoes DNA
sorry cell division and exposes that
head of that deleterious allele so the
question we're asking here is what about
plants the plants have the exact same
issue as single-celled organisms or
animals or are they somewhere in between
all right so let's think about it do we
expect plants to have programmed cell
cycle responses to DNA damage at all of
course we do because it's a very
sensitive sensible thing to do but let's
just play devil's advocate for a second
here plants are diploid and often
polyploid and they tolerate any pretty
well they have backup copies of things
in my case I'm working with the rapid
opsys arabidopsis is self pollinating
organisms so it's homozygous for all low
sides so it's not going to be exposing
heterozygosity by Lee losing a
chromosome arm because it's already
totally inbred plant cells can't move so
cancers can metastasize so even if you
messed up the regulation of the cell
cycle in a single cell you might end up
with a tumor on a plant but you rather
you'd probably not end up with death and
again the case of arabidopsis we have a
10-week life cycle anyway really doesn't
matter where development is extremely
flexible so if some cells are messed up
and starting to take off on their own
and there aren't many examples of them
ever doing this you know you know
viruses or bacteria can reprogram cells
that sells rarely ignore the signals
from other cells so this is an example
of the flexibility of plant growth in
that you can take a fig tree in this
case a ficus and you can turn it into
boards and you can pound them into
ground and staple barbed wire to them
and if there's any living tissues to
the board he'll make another tree right
some animals don't do this but plants
can easily do this sort of thing so they
can work around a lot of problems now
still why not do cell cycle arrest well
the reason not to his plants compete for
resources only through growth animals
don't do that they can run around and
compete for resources plant if these
plants too little seedlings are going
next to each other and they're competing
for light if one gets bigger than the
other even transiently it will
overshadow the other and have an
exponential advantage that will never
stop it's a little like uncontrolled
capitalism right if you don't have
government regulations in place as soon
as one person gets rich he can dominate
all the others so in this case sorry
yeah plants have to worry about growth
rate versus genetic purity which is
really a more important issue so if this
immediately leads us to think about
somatic vs. germline cells maybe it's
okay to grow like mad and ignore genome
fidelity as long as you're outpacing
your competitors that the germline
perhaps is something you don't want that
to happen in and unfortunately I'm not
going to be talking about the germline
in this talk at all because it's harder
to look at than the root tip so instead
I'll talk a little bit about
meristematic versus terminally
differentiated cells and how their
responses might be different all right
so do double strand breaks occur at all
in nature there is no natural source of
radiation that plants really have to
worry about the kind of doses i'm using
are enormous you're even if you were
growing plants in chernobyl where they
grow just fine they wouldn't get the
sort of dose all right so double strand
breaks are generated during your DNA
replication quite frequently so these
are single and double strand breaks due
to breakage of a replication fork so
larger genomes will have bigger problems
with this sort of issue and here's an
example of what I'm talking about if you
have a replication fork and there's
maybe a single-sided you know a lesion
just one base DNA polymerase is various
paths Didius and it doesn't want to
replicate
past that it's going to leave
single-stranded DNA on both of these
sides and that is a very fragile thing
and so it's quite likely for one of
these branches to break off right this
is essentially in a complete chromosome
that's fine but this is a chromosome
that has a break and nothing to rejoin
it to so that's a single-ended break so
every round of replication this probably
happens in every cell in a rabid abscess
the genome sizes 130th besides of me so
I think it would happen 30 times more
often amazed than in arabidopsis double
strand breaks can also be generated
naturally during desiccation and
rehydration and i don't mean drought I
mean desiccation when biological tissues
reach you know air levels of humidity
they're just left out to dry out and
animals most animals cannot withstand
desiccation but some fun G can and
plants can seed plants do it every
generation in the seeds sometimes pollen
is desiccation tolerant and some kinds
of pollen or not so this is another
example of where double strand breaks
could be generated substantially in the
genome and of course bigger genomes just
because they're more DNA have a greater
probability of getting a double strand
break and is this damage acute so we're
throughout this talk going to be talking
about acute damage right slam the plant
with gamma radiation then I look at its
recovery rather than leaving it to grow
on something that induces double strand
breaks is damaged two seeds acute it
depends whether you believe that seeds
in their desiccated crypto biotic state
are actually still to be metabolically
active repairing things but there is an
older literature about the fact that
seeds if you watch them germinate they
will undergo what's called unscheduled
DNA replication which means that all of
the cells are doing a little repair here
and there and once that period is done
then the seed will actually proceed with
cell division and it won't do that so it
seems to be cleaning up its genome at
the beginning of replicas of germination
after its involved and then it goes on
with its life so it's a little like
suffering
the cute dose of DNA damage it suddenly
wakens to the fact that it has
accumulated DNA damage all right our
model system is the rabbit opposite
seedling it has highly stereotypical
development we know what all the cells
are doing pretty well it has lots of
easily visualized cell types it has a
variety of cell cycle nodes so if we
look at this young arab adopts seedling
the different cells are doing different
things and this is a plant audience
mostly so i could go through this pretty
quickly there's a apical meristem here
and in apical meristem down here and
both of these regions are rapidly
dividing and there's sort of a stem cell
niche that's creating all these new
cells those are my taught excels now
unlike animals there's also a lot of
enduro duplication so all of the growth
of the hypocotyl after germination
through expansion of cells not cell
division and so those are becoming end
or duplicated undergoing s phase but not
M phase and the cells are getting bigger
and bigger same thing in the zone of
elongation in the route after they're
done being mitotic the cells will start
to expand and increase the copy number
of the DNA without undergoing cell
division and then there's
differentiation sort of after that
expansion has done so we are looking at
all kinds of different cell cycles when
we radiate these seedlings every single
cell is getting the exact same dose a
breaks right the radiation as I said
goes right through there's no higher
dose to outside sales than inside sounds
everything's getting the same dose but
there the cells have different destinies
and so they might have different
responses to DNA damage all right do
plants exhibit program responses to DNA
damage and of course yes I wouldn't be
talking here and how first the questions
more intellectual questions to ask how
do you know responses programmed rather
than just a toxic effect for instance if
you if you expose a plant to drought you
might see it wilt you might think poor
plant its suffering from drought but it
is in a way undergoing a programmed
response to that drab it's dropping its
leaves so it's not pick
up as much Sun is that used to it's
doing this intentionally so we're trying
to distinguish between intentional
responses which we call programmed and
toxic inevitable effects of ionizing
radiation then for the programmed
responses we'd like to know how they're
regulated and we want to know what their
biological significance is too all right
so most cases we will be irradiated
seedlings but sometimes we were radiate
seeds so this is the mature embryo for
rabid opsys inside of its seed it has
two cotyledons it has a roof and has no
truly no visible true leaves at all
there's a meristem that will divide to
give true leaves so if you radiate at
this stage for wild-type seeds we look a
couple weeks later you have plenty of
true leaves you can spot them with there
Leif hairs hundred greys basically no
effect I'm good this is a dose that is
about 30 times the dose that would kill
a person but the genome size is 130th
that of the human genome size but this
is you know clearly it's not a lethal
dose at all has no effect on growth if
irradiated is seeds now if we take that
up to 500 Grey's which is that 150
double strand breaks / diploid g1 genome
we actually see miniaturization of
everything the cuddling is everything
that was in the embryo is alive it's
gravitropism growing and the cells are
miniaturized then awfully not expanding
so is that a toxic effect or a program
to effect I can't tell you another thing
we can look at that's an effect of
ionizing radiation is mutagenesis so we
have this assay for mutagenesis where
you have a foster resistant knock out of
an allele that calls it causes albinism
so we can select for heterozygotes they
have to be green and they have to be
basta resistant and then we can
irradiated xand asked what the rate of
sectoring is and the rate of sectoring
if you don't you radiate the the seeds
of zero you can't look it enough to to
find those sectors but if you radiate
them you can produce these sectors that
reflect chromosome loss right
I don't know what it's a very large
broad net that catches all niente shins
at this locus and it maxes out at about
four percent of plants because the
plants get smaller and smaller and
smaller and smaller until you can't look
at scepters anymore as part of their
program DNA damage response but that
sectoring mutagenesis itself it's hard
to believe that's a programmed response
that is a toxic effect of ionizing
radiation now you think cell death would
also be a toxic effective ionizing
radiation but the reason you die from
five grades of radiation is not because
your epithelial intestinal lining is
especially sensitive to ionizing
radiation it's because it's a sensitive
to the response to destroy itself in
response to ionizing radiation so you
slough off here uh put all your
epidermal cells similarly here if we
look at plants we radiate the whole root
tip everybody gets the same dose but we
get def not entirely just you know I can
see a dead cell here p I staining
indicates that the cells can no longer
pump out p high and so they start to
glow and you might say well maybe this
is a highly mitotic population that
makes it more sensitive because it's
running through the cell cycle faster
but if we look at the mitotic population
using cyclin b1 one gfp as a marker we
see that this whole mass of cells here
is highly mitotic and they're not all
dying it's instead focused on the stem
cells for the steal of the moon yeah all
right which suggests that it's a
programmed response rather than a toxic
response another thing that sells root
tips do in response to radiation is
here's a root tip growing four days old
eight days old here's a root cap you
can't see any root hairs because they're
farther up the root if you hit them with
ionizing radiation four days later you
can start to see root hairs as
differentiation approaches the root tip
the root tip has stopped dividing and
stopped growing away from the
differentiating zone it's coming down if
eight days all the cells have become
massive and huge the entire root tip has
swollen up their root hairs
everywhere because there's no cell
division and the root tip is not growing
away from this differentiation zone so
we you could say that this is premature
and education and differentiation or you
could say it's just waiting for
differentiation to catch up with it
another cute phenotype is this if we
look at this DNA repair mutant xpf
that's defective in a flap and de
nucleus whea radiate these plants as
seeds wild-type is not sensitive to this
dose the DNA repair mutant is these
cotyledons are still undergoing cell
division there's not a lot of cell
division in the cotyledon naturally but
there's a there's a formation of stomata
for example that's all post embryonic
and that's still a current those cell
divisions are still occurring but these
cell divisions to make leaves or not so
again that suggests it's a programmed
response some cells are undergoing
arrest or death other cells are not okay
so how do we know which responses are
due to DNA damage because ionizing
radiation affects everything yourself
and how do we know which responses are
programmed versus direct effects well to
look at the responsibility of DNA damage
we can't quite do that directly but we
can do a fairly convincing experiment or
what we do is look at mutants that are
defective and end-to-end non-homologous
end joining of double-strand breaks so
in a g1 cell this is what's doing the
bulk of the DNA repair the ends are
simply relocated together it's a
reasonably error-free process so long as
the ants haven't been receptive there is
also this gene which I mentioned before
xpf which is a flat fender nucleation
sometimes required for some types of
non-homologous end joining all right so
we can look at these and we can ask if
you're defective and double strand break
repair do you mimic the effects of
ionizing radiation at a lower dose you
know in the mutant that any phenotype
you see is due to this deficiency
and therefore due to double strand
breaks so for example if we look at a
DNA ligase for mutant at zero grades of
radiation its wild-type and a hundred
grades of radiation when irradiated
their seeds it makes this miniaturized
tiny cotyledon little seedling that's
not going to grow again and this mimics
the effects of 500 Gray's of radiation
alright similarly at only 20 Gray's of
radiation before we looked at 100
wild-type is very slow to induce any
cell death in the root tip it's not
particularly focused there either but if
we look at DNA ligase for at 20 Gray's
we can see within four hours there
starts to be cell death so this is also
apparently a response to double strand
breaks doesn't mean it's programmed but
it's responsive double strand breaks and
interestingly different kinds of
persisting DNA damage can induce
different effects on growth so I just
talked about xpf having this lovely
phenotype that we call the gamma
plantlet in which everything is normal
color hypocotyl developments normal
cotyledon development is normal but
you're just not getting true leads as
opposed to a DNA leg is for it the same
dose which has this highly militarized
seedling there is no dose of gamma
radiation where we can get like four to
look like this right so it's not just a
matter of degree right by the time the
cotyledons look this good we have true
leaves also so this is a response to
something that's a very potent signal
for telling these cells to not divided
whereas this is a response to something
that's making all cells miniaturized and
inhibiting growth right again this
differential sensitivity of these cells
versus these cells again these still
have cell division they still performing
for us to Mata suggests that this is a
programmed response all right so we felt
so strongly that this was a programmed
response that Sasha Bruce was willing to
undergo a genetic screen to look for
regulators of this so if it's a program
response there must be something that's
telling the cell here's a break this is
what you should do in response to it or
whatever it is
xpf is repairing right so he took the
xpf line and he mutagenized seen through
the MS and he treated them actually with
a hundred greys and then he looked for
plant that could grow in spite of the
fact that they've been irradiated so
he's looking for true leaf production
and he found several mutants and one of
them was sawed one you can see the
leaves are not great but the phila taxi
is normal and the time at which they're
produced is normal so the leaves are
struggling but they're still emerging so
they've lost the ability to induce
probably a checkpoint in apical meristem
and sub 1 as tomo discovered is also
defective in this program cell death so
if we look at sub 1 at 0 4 and eight
hours after irradiation someone has no
cell death it's not sensitive to
ionizing radiation in a way it's
resistant again because this is a
program response and saw one tells you
it's a programmed response but this is
not happening it's not a toxic effect
it's something the cells are doing
intentionally and just as to be entirely
forthcoming with you if we go to the
next day and we look at saw one mutants
we do see cell death so here's wild-type
24 hours you see this focus cell death
here's SOG you see this checkerboard
cell death instead hasn't got the focus
and same thing we go to 48 hours we see
continuing cell death so this is saga an
independent cell death I don't know if
it's programmed or not right this is
clearly programmed and stuff at the
earlier time points alright so if losing
sagwan is so great for the plant because
it doesn't have cell death they can go
on and divide in spite of radiation what
is sog 14 well it's the same thing any
checkpoint protein is for is to prevent
the accumulation of mutations so if you
radiate seeds again with that albino
pale green marker and we look for
sectors here's wild-type xpf xpf plus
sog and just saw by itself
so this is suggesting that sog one is
really important for minimizing
heritable DNA damage induced by ionizing
radiation so it can control chromosomal
stability it does this by inhibiting
progression at the cell cycle haven't
showed you all this data it switches
cells from a mitotic to enter
reduplicated cell cycle so again as long
as you are not doing cell division
double strand breaks are not a problem
and it induces cell death in dividing
meristematic cells alright so the
isolation of mutants defective in these
responses indicates that they're
programmed responses rather than toxic
effects of radiation alright so Carol
yoshiyama was postdoc in the lab and she
mapped SOG and figured out what gene it
was and it turned out to be a
transcription factor an appt domain
family protein it has a single amino
acid change from a glycine that's
entirely conserved in all 100 nak domain
proteins and rabid opsys to an arginine
and it looks like unfortunately you know
we would love to be able to go to NIH
and say we're going to look for some
mutants and humans or something but the
snack domain family does not exist
outside the plant world infected only
exists in land plants and if I want to
really go out on a limb I could say that
you couldn't become a land plant without
SOG because it's important for response
to desiccation but that's really pushing
it okay anyway you can find homologues
of SOG as opposed to other neck domain
proteins in related angiosperms so they
have more closely related genes to SOG
than to the next neck domain protein in
a rabid opsys so they probably are all
carrying this response but it hasn't
been shown at all now SOG itself is not
transcriptionally induced by ionizing
radiation it's always present and that
makes sense for the master regulator is
going to be at the top of the chain has
to be present to detect the DNA damage
so how does it do that well damage
sensors are conserved among eukaryotes
and there are two classes and sometimes
they trade off some funk
shins but you can distinguish between
them pretty well there's ATM which
detects double strand breaks directly
with the help of other factors and
there's a TR which slightly indirectly
detects persisting single-stranded
stretches of DNA not single store breaks
but single-stranded DNA s uses these
factors to do that both of these sort of
touch the lesion before becoming
activated then this is in mammals
there's a check one and check to
Karnazes these don't exist in plants at
all so plants have the detectors don't
necessarily have the same connections
but when you get down to the regulation
of the cell cycle itself of course they
do share some factors and we one is one
of them alright so for instance this
gamma plantlet formation which these are
all irradiated seeds here's wild-type
it's resistant to radiation here's xpf
making a lovely gamma plantlet here's
xpf SOG making these sort of crappy
looking true leaves if we look at ATM
ATM still has the arrest so HMU is not
required for that arrest if we look at
ATR mutant we get the true leads back
again and they look a lot better than
some too so eight ER is apparently
detecting whatever lesion it is that ex
BF is leaving behind himself ATM is not
requiring for that ATR is absolutely
required and in fact we one is also
required for the detection so this is
probably some kind of replication block
and we want as part of that pathway into
that
okay so SOG one is a transcription
factor so does the rabid opsins have a
transcriptional response to ionizing
radiation so with this experiment is to
take five day old seedlings irradiate
not seeds but seedlings with a hundred
grays which is a dose that slows them
down a little but then they all can
recover from that is and look at the
entire transcriptome at 1.53 6 12 24
hours which is presented on a time line
across here and the red bars are genes
that are repressed and green bars are
genes that are I'm sorry red is induced
and green is repressed and this has been
sorted by the computer into similar
expression patterns so there are
hundreds of genes that are induced and
peak between about one and three hours
right here there are also hundreds of
genes that are so suppressed and that
maximum suppression is about it now I
nope sorry six hours six hours and these
include transcripts that promote cell
cycle progression and then there's this
little cluster of genes that are induced
at twelve hours also all right so is
this a response to double strand breaks
or is this a response to damage to other
cellular components it could be both if
we look at the list of genes that are
induced the most highly induced genes
and these are all on a few chips the
fold induction for jeans like breca one
which are extremely repressed under
normal conditions in the cell is highly
variable when you do the experiment
depending on how you process the data
from the chips and where you draw the
line about background levels of
expression so I don't know that this is
really induced 581 fold it's certainly
not to to the 581 we're just talking
about 581 full all right so if you look
at this you can see wild-type is
inducing these genes to these degrees
and if you look at the list of genes and
you happen to know anything that DNA
metabolism you can see that they're all
DNA metabolism genes all right ATR
mutation has no effect on the induction
those jeans ATM is critical for the
induction of these jeans so at this time
point in response to gamma radiation HTM
is driving the induction of this cluster
this little red cluster of jeans okay
all right so if we then go ahead and
expose the ATM mutant you can see that a
lot of this response is still going on
but not this cluster so ATM that's the
double strand break response because ATM
is a double strand break detector you
can see that we're still getting
repression of the cell cycle and that's
because if we look at gene by Gene basis
ATM and ATR both play semi redundant
roles in that response so this is a TR
driven in an ATM background ok so what
about SOG sounds the transcription
factor what does it regulate in this
response and what Karen found is that it
regulates everything so for this little
cluster again of jeans SOG one is
essential for its induction so saban
must be a transcription factor that
doesn't bind to every one of these
promoters but perhaps binds to the
promoters of transcription factors that
then bind to the promoter of these so
SOG one is remarkably important for this
response all right how does saawan work
Cal had a paper published recently she
went on to work on this saag one has um
we knew that it had a SQ motif a couple
of them that were highly predicted to be
regulated by both ATM and ATR so what
our model is is ATM is induced by adele
strand break it becomes an active kinase
and it activates the activity of
pre-existing saw one protein and this
goes on to reduce other text you okay
and again if you're interested you can
see Kelly's paper here
alright so we talked a little bit before
about what relevance does ionizing
radiation have for plant biology at all
because obviously plants have a lovely
programmed response to it but it's never
encountered in nature so something that
DNA repair people like to say in the
literature is for instance any
conventional stress induces reactive
oxygen species and that induces DNA
damage and this is probably important
for response to stress but if you
actually use this stress this DNA damage
response as an indicator for the
presence of double-strand breaks we
could say if we look at other stresses
do we see the induction of this response
at all so again here's with gamma this
is another kind of ionizing radiation
hce this is in the ATM mutant and this
is a particularly nice diagnostic
cluster of transcripts that are ATM
dependent induced so if we unmask all
this and look at some other stresses
salt osmotic drought cold heat blah blah
blah blah blah we are not seeing these
clusters of genes so again we've
clustered expression based just on gamma
and then we've extended that analysis to
look at other stresses and we see a nice
block here this is geno toxic stress
it's a combination of M&MS and mitomycin
c so again it's just a DNA repair
experiment hydroxyurea is an inhibitor
of DNA replication and you can see a
little bear but if we look at these more
generic stresses you know if you squint
you can see it in salt and that's the
roots as opposed to the shoots and this
is UVB you can see it a little bit but
that's about it all right so if we look
at the go category and we've already
discussed this a little of these ATM
dependent game induced genes it's it's
massively over-represented for RNA and
DNA metabolism and if we again look
through all these stresses and just take
the RNA and DNA
tablets and genes that we really
understand and look really hard for
their induction buygeneric stress we
don't see it right so this response is
not there to deal with generics dresses
it may be there to deal with seed
storage okay so this is just what I told
you here surprisingly it's not even used
by paraquat which is specifically a ross
and do sir so what's different between
paraquat and ionizing radiation again
ionizing radiation is producing clusters
of ross the amount of energy deposited
in a very small area is very high in you
damage both strands normal Ross just
doesn't do that damages single basis
happens all the times in plants and
they're very very good at coping using
excision repair to repair singly damaged
basis okay so desiccation tolerance and
radiation tolerance seem to be two sides
of the same coin so this is a famous
organism that's extremely radiation
resistant and it was found that it's
also extremely desiccation assistant
mutants that are sensitive to I are also
sensitive to dehydration if you do the
transcriptomic the two stresses induced
the same thing and dehydration indeed
induces massive amounts of breaks it's
not just dehydration it's dehydration
rehydration cycling and Chris West and
Wanda water worth have done some
research on this and they have shown
that as the plant as a rabid opsys e
disse germinating there's a one or two
hour window during imbibition at which
you see the induction of this response
and then it goes away again but you have
to really take thin slices of time to
see that so and they've also shown DNA
lag is for is important for seed
longevity so that probably is what this
really elaborate response is all about
okay so to summarize so far not going to
get all the way through this talk for
sure that we're looking at the immediate
actual response to double strand breaks
and rabid opsys has a robust very
producible transcriptional response to
IR which is governed by ATM and south
one and transcriptional response to IR
is important in mammals and funky p53 is
a transcription factor but it is nowhere
near this amplitude for this
reproducibility all right the
transcription the scrimps induced early
after irds be specific and you can see
that a rabid opsys induces a program
cell death response that is also ATM
insulin-dependent to both UV which i
didn't discuss in ionizing radiation
this is focused largely in the precursor
cells of the steal alright so we know
that different cells respond in
different ways into gamma radiation and
so we can ask is the short-term
transcriptional response different in
different cells so this requires the
presence of SOG one solved one's a
transcription factor we can cross our
fingers and hope that these cells have a
different transcriptional response then
these cells around them and if we could
do the transcriptomics of just these
cells it might give us a clue as to some
of the connecting dots between the
double strand breaks and the induction
of cell death all right so just as an
example of the cell type specificity of
DNA damage response film made this
construct of Recca one promoter used to
Alyssa phrase and what he's going to do
is going to take the same plate here
he's going to collect 20 minute batches
of photons for nine hours after
radiation so again this is exact same
plate and here are these plants growing
you can see the true leaves the
cotyledons are dimmer this is it one
hour and here's the root tip and when
you watch this and will cycle through it
several times you might check out the
root tip first and then you can look
farther up to see what's going on next
time around so here it goes we're at
three hours and this flare has come up
and now it's starting to disappear
here's something particularly beautiful
you see these evenly spaced spots a
breca one induction so we're coming
round again
if we look higher up we can see the root
tips of the lateral roots lighting up
later than the root tip down here and
one more time we can also see at this
time point evenly spaced white spots
within the room but you're probably the
areas where the lateral roots are going
to come out and emerge later that's not
clear to me that those cells are
dividing already but they know that
their meristem already okay so in the
case of breka one we can clearly see
that timing is different for different
cell types and some cells never express
rekha one and some cells express it more
strongly there's lots in the highly
mitotic new leaves there's lesson
already developed cotyledons so in case
of record one will probably see
induction only in cells that undergo or
can undergo are are undergoing DNA
replication because braca one is
involved in homologous repair of
double-strand breaks and that occurs
during S phase in g2 because it uses his
sister chromatid as a template to repair
the DNA so the process at least in
mammals is very cell cycle regulated and
it's absolutely suppressed in g1 so Phil
went on to us does the quality of the
transcriptional response very with cell
type so this was all about quantity and
timing for one cell so we're going to go
ahead and do the transcriptomics for a
particular cell type and sells
type-specific transcriptomics can tell
us lots of things they help us identify
first transcripts that we would never
have seen on a whole ground-up seedling
because they're only be induced say in
four cells that you're interested in
you're going to have to do a lot of work
to isolate those four cells and look at
them and then but suddenly that signal
will stand out we wouldn't have seen it
before now cell Phil's not looking at
just four cells he's looking a whole
batch of cells that turned out to be
about five percent of the total cells of
the root tips that he's looking at you
can identify candidate genes for
regulators of the effectors of cell
type-specific processes and that's the
gold that we're really looking for in
this kind of
experiment is to identify new regulators
and you know just looking at go analysis
can provide clues as to what's going on
ok so again we're going to attempt to
isolate these cells we can't do this
perfectly but we're going to use is a p
wooden leg dnp fusion that labels these
really the dividing steel cells the ones
that are still undergoing replication so
the timing we didn't have a lot of money
so we didn't do a lot of time points
just one Phil chose something between
four hours at which you could see no
cell death and six hours at which he
could after radiation and as protocol is
this so we're taking the d f p+ line
we're cutting off just the root tips and
throwing away the top of the plant there
we're going to protoplast the root tips
we're going to sell sort away the GF p
plus and collect this population it's
about 5% of this population now Phil did
not sort away what we're drawing here is
red versus green he just took the entire
thing so we're comparing GF p plus to
the entire and just to show that the
sort worked short route is the
transcript that should only be expressed
in this population and you can see that
it's enhanced for expression of short
route whereas actin is expressed
throughout and you can see that if you
take the entire root tip versus a GF p
plus positive these are pretty much the
same but short loop is engaged here so
the sort worked and just to go through
this really quickly this is he's doing
is RNA seek analysis most of this is
gibberish to me but i trust my people in
my lab if we do the go analysis of these
genes that are induced in both tissues
equally what we see or is this gamma
response that we discussed before the
risk a week the response to double
strand breaks so this is happening in
the outer shell and in the inner core of
the group tip both of them or responding
to double strand breaks this is just
telling you the same thing repressed in
both tissues is the cell cycle so all
these things about building yourselves
is being shut down
temporarily while the roof tip is
responding to this under grace radiation
if we look at jeans that are induced
more strongly in the gfp plus which is
really what we're looking for that's why
we're doing the experiment and you look
at these go categories and again these
go calories are somewhat redundant in
the same genes may be falling into
multiple gold categories these all have
to do with immune response so as plant
biologists I'm sure you're sensitive
with a hypersensitive response to
pathogen and this is suggesting that
there are commonalities between the two
probably the detection is different but
it may be that the cell death itself is
similar and the connection somewhere
those two processes meet up into the
same signal transduction chain perhaps
so we're seeing a similar effect again
and do specifically in the population
that's going to die and this is just
showing you the relative fold induction
and gfp plus vs. the entire root tip
here and fill took a couple of these
jeans made gfp fusions transform them
into plants and he can get some very
pretty pictures without ionizing
radiation this is a senescence
associated gene 14 this is with if you
look carefully and you know your root
tip morphology you see that this is not
part of this deal so even though we're
purifying cells in the steel this is
also induced outside of this deal but it
is induced right here in the root tip
and it's very iron inducible and there's
lots of expression within this deal
alright so that we told you that the
cell type-specific transcriptomics can
identify transcripts from Sue's f two
cell types whose signals are normally
swamped and that's another interesting
result that Phil got there is a gene
called erf 115 which is very hard to
detect because it's very very poorly
expressed and he sees it as being
induced in his GF p plus population by
ir and what is the function of this gene
leavin devel ders lab had this paper in
science 2013 erf 115 if it's over
expressed causes the cells in the QC you
know the sort of organizing core of the
root tip to divide so it stimulates
division of the QC so it's interesting
that at a time in which cell division is
being actively repressed in the root tip
this stimulating gene that's specific
for the QC is being induced and Phil and
I are still arguing about this but I
believe we're also seeing induction of
walks five which is another QC specific
transcript right that suppresses
division of cells in the QC so I think
what we're seeing is induction of QC
identity in tissues where it shouldn't
be present okay so the other thing we
promised you is that we could identify
candidate genes for regulators or
effectors and cell cycle specific prof
processes and this is where our story
gets a little bit sad because we're just
starting to look at this but I don't
know so Phil took 15 different
homozygous exonic insertion lines
representing 10 of these are induced
transcripts and none of them were mutant
for PCD program cell death and he took
seven exonic insertion lines
representing seven repressed transcript
and none of them were meeting for PCD
and then he just got a little desperate
a took 11 genes that govern already
known to govern hypersensitive response
and none of them were mutant for PCB
either so you know we need to look more
carefully at this but no one is
particularly motivated to because listen
says it's rather depressing result in
the beginning so the conclusions for
part two and I don't think I can go on
to part three but I do want to show you
just one picture roots can recover from
massive doses of IR this is the early
results so I haven't I haven't discussed
this yet the transcriptional response is
required no this is all later so I'm
going to go into this talking about day
one a little bit so this is things that
happen after day one so the root tip
undergo cell death in this program to a
later time points that spreads up the
word is going to have to recover because
it will at this dose recover and go on
with growth as plant biologists you're
familiar with the QC which is a
population of about four cells that
basically provide identity this but as a
DNA repair and recovery person I have
always thought of the QC as a population
of cells that is intentionally never
dividing so that it never has problems
with DNA damage it's not undergoing
replication making replication errors is
not cycling so it's not so sensitive to
double strand breaks and it's there to
replace these cells which are foolish
enough to be dividing so so that's a
great reason to have a quiescent center
but what I'm seeing when I look at the
expression of QC identity after
radiation makes me think that perhaps
this is incorrect so just to move on
with this okay if we look at a wild-type
plant we give it 150 Gray's of radiation
we watch the root growth over the days
there's still growth during the period
after a radiation because once the
growth is elongation you don't need to
put supply new cells you'll run out of
new cells by then the meristem starts
growing again and use get root growth
again if you look at a sog mutant at
this dose the SOG mutant actually stops
growing and doesn't recover so saugus
doing something that's important for
recovery of the root tip 24 hours after
150
Greys you can see that on wild-type is
experienced a fair amount of cell death
this particular dose this particular
experiment we can still see the QC in
these root tips not getting cell death
and this is the complimented line just
to control to show you that's really a
solve one dependent effect we look three
days after 150 gray we're starting to
get elongation of these cells as the
differentiation zone proceeds down
towards the rib tip we can no longer see
the QC in wild-type so this structure is
getting messed up still look nice and
organized in song and if you put them on
constitutive rather than acute
dna-damaging agent saga lovely compared
with wild-type so it maintains its root
shape and again this complemented line
QC is gone we can't see it if we look
five days after can still see the QC and
saag we only see a mess in these root
tips and then seven days after the
situation changes the root tip has
recovered in wild-type it's reestablish
and has grown away from all that big fat
cell crap the root tip is now growing
again same thing here and
differentiation has preceded all the way
down to the tip and saw and it's not
going to be meristem anymore alright so
if you look at the growth day after day
both of these things keep growing and
then they slow down when they finally
stopped growing they produce a lot of
root hairs at this point and leaves what
we call a scar so you can tell where
they stopped and then as the days go on
a new meristem will be formed in
wild-type it has to reorganize itself
and then will grow away from all of this
mess giving you this growth curve here
interestingly if you look at expression
of walks five which is a QC specific
gene transcript what you see is that as
the days proceed after radiation in
wild-type and we haven't looked at saw
yet because we don't have the line yet
walks five expression spreads throughout
the root tip so it's as if all of these
cells are volunteering
for the position of new QC and when this
root tip finally re-emerged 'as you're
back to having walks five expression
only in those four cell so somehow the
QC is selecting among all these
potentially crappy cells to find perhaps
a really good one that is going to make
up the new QC which is a bit of a
stretch but that's what this integer
okay so i should just move on to thank
the people responsible for this so you
may have met Phil Conklin he's moved
here Mike Scanlon lab just recently and
he and Victor were responsible for a lot
of the transcriptomics analysis but
filled it all that wet lab type of
experiments and this is just to thank
the rest of my lab who's doing other
projects and other things that you can
ask me about to and of course I'd like
to thank the students again for inviting
me here it's been a pleasure so far this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu